at least nine people have been killed in
a cable car accident in northern italy
the stress of
a cable car takes tourists from the town
of stresa up almost
1400 metres above sea level to the top
of the monterey
mountain let's speak to our europe
correspondent michelle clifford
michelle what happened
well the information that we've been
hearing is that the cable car
broke away from its moorings fell to the
ground
um in terms of the number of people have
died sadly we're hearing that nine
people have died
that there are 11 people on board this
particular
capsule and two children have been taken
to hospital now
this is an area frequented by uh
tourists regularly also by locals and so
because of the situation at the moment
in terms of covered we
we have no information whether they were
tourists or locals
the only thing that seems to be
confirmed is that at least nine people
have
died that 11 people have been taken to
hospital
and that's the information that we're
getting out from the
uh the police the local authorities via
local
media but it is a very popular area
um what seems to have happened is that
this
cable car broke away from its moorings
and it's clearly a very
it's an evolving situation we're waiting
to hear
more information but we heard we have
heard 11 people
were on board um local reports suggest
that nine people have died and two
people have been taken or two children
have been taken to hospital okay
michelle thank you